دعهم يتحدثون مرة واحدة وبعد ذلك
دعونا نعزف سمفونيتنا وإلا فلنذهب
أنا الآن من BÜ
[موسيقى]
حنين
لدينا
أ
رجل
[موسيقى]
لقد توصلنا إلى اتفاق على ذلك
أخبر الشباب أنك تريد ذلك الآن
كلنا نستمع دون تعليق
لدي لهم لدي لهم
وعدت، نظرا لكلمة الشرف الخاصة بي
لن يتم ترك أي تعليقات هنا
الأعذار ومن ثم دعونا نفعل ذلك
لعب الحركة الرابعة الرجاء المساعدة
هنا اليوم لأننا قلقون للغاية
جدا أن لدينا هذا المفهوم و
يجب أن ينكسر ولكن لدينا واحدة
الطوارئ المناخية
[موسيقى]
وقف المطر
من فضلك لأنه يهمنا جميعا
دعهم يتحدثون مرة واحدة وبعد ذلك
دعونا نعزف سمفونيتنا وإلا فلنذهب
أنا خارج المصنع الآن إذا كان لديك
لا اسمحوا لي أن أعذرك ثم لدي الألغام
كلمة مكسورة
[موسيقى]